welcome everyone
this is a the second of a two-part
lecture series the 2023 Castle lecture
series
um I for those who were not here
yesterday I am pleased to introduce our
speaker today Ben Weisner who is the
director of the ACLU speech privacy and
Technology project
yesterday Ben started to build up the
foundations of his argument and deliver
an engaging and thought-provoking
account of a Freedom of Information Act
lawsuit
seeking to release a few dozen pages of
records from the Guantanamo Bay prison
this lawsuit as he argued illustrates
how the National Security Law affects
Democratic accountability
today Ben will continue his critical
analysis of the National Security Law
and as I mentioned yesterday the castle
lectures
aim to promote awareness of the ethical
challenges and complexities of our
society and Foster a robust dialogue of
the moral foundations of society and
government this lecture series were made
possible because of a generous gift by
John Castle who is in the audience with
us today
thank you so much
we are grateful for the support of Mr
Castle both to the epne program and for
Yale more broadly this gift was made in
honor of his ancestor Reverend James
Pierpont a Harper trained Congressional
Minister who founded the Collegiate
School of Connecticut in 1701. soon
thereafter renamed for his benefit its
benefactor Eliot Yale
we are very grateful to Ben for
accepting the invitation to deliver this
year lecture
and for his willingness to discuss with
our community such a relevant and
complex topic as the interconnection of
National Security and Democratic
accountability
the format of today's lecture is going
to be the same as yesterday so Ben will
talk for about 50 minutes
and then we're going to have plenty of
time for Q a
so I please ask you to welcome me in
giving Ben the floor Ben thank you so
much for being with us today
thank you very much Anna for that kind
introduction again and thank you all for
being here especially those who I'm
seeing for the second day in a row
uh if anything to those of you who are
new seems underdeveloped it's simply
because you weren't here yesterday
[Laughter]
in September of 2011 Harvard Law School
and the Brookings institution which
publishes the law fair blog a kind of
online Clubhouse for the National
Security set hosted a two-day conference
to Mark the 10-year anniversary of the 9
11 attacks
among the event luminaries was John
Brennan at that time Obama's Chief
counter-terrorism advisor and later the
director of Central Intelligence who
delivered a lunchtime keynote address
I joined the queue of people waiting to
ask him a question and when my turn came
I asked
does the CIA have a drone program
the audience erupted in laughter
Brennan responded well as you know
covert actions are designed to be covert
and therefore and therefore you only
read about them in the newspaper I
interrupted
if the agency did have such a program he
said to more laughter I'm sure it would
be done with the utmost Karen Precision
in accordance with the law in our values
if such a program existed
at the close of yesterday's lecture we
discussed the legal fiction that forms
the pillar of the intelligence
community's impunity regime
that there is a critical distinction
between what is universally known
and what is officially confirmed
anyone unfamiliar with that fiction
would have been bewildered by my
exchange with Brennan wasn't the cia's
Drone program in newspapers almost every
day
and weren't those stories essentially
readouts from government sources
two weeks after the Harvard conference
Anwar al-alaki a U.S citizen born in Las
Cruces New Mexico was killed in Yemen by
a Hellfire missile fired from a U.S
predator drone
this targeted killing
came as no surprise the entire world
knew that the United States had Marked
alaki for Death nearly two years earlier
that's because in early 2010 senior
Obama administration officials in a
coordinated media strategy leaked to
Leading newspapers that alaki had been
added to secret kill lists maintained by
the CIA and Department of defense's
joint Special Operations Command
these off the Record leaks were a
deliberate policy decision
the Obama Administration wanted the
public to know of its controversial
decision
to Target a U.S citizen for death based
on undisclosed criteria and evidence
a national security law we always arrive
sooner or later at the bottom of a
previously announced slippery slope
at oral argument before the fourth
Circuit Court of Appeals in the al-masri
case which I discussed yesterday
I had warned the court
that if El masri's claims of kidnapping
and torture could be dismissed on
secrecy grounds then the state Secrets
privilege will be employed routinely to
shield from liability even at the most
egregious acts the government could and
would
make the identical argument even if the
claim involved extrajudicial murder
and even if the plaintiff were an
American citizen
could in wood and did
in August of 2010 the ACLU and the
center for constitutional rights
responded to the slew of news stories
announcing that alaki had been added to
government kill lists by filing a
lawsuit challenging the government's
asserted authority to carry out targeted
killings of U.S citizens located far
from any armed conflict Zone
the U.S was not at war with Yemen or
within it we argued
and outside of armed conflict both the
Constitution and international law
prohibited deliberate killing except as
a last resort to protect against
concrete specific and imminent threats
in extrajudicial killing policy under
which names were added to kill lists
shopping lists for death
through some kind of secret executive
process and remain there for months was
plainly not limited to imminent threats
and because ilaki was a U.S citizen he
had a due process right to know what
conduct might subject him to execution
at the hands of his own government
in response to our lawsuit the
government having deliberately invited a
public debate about its asserted
authority to kill ilaki now decided that
having that debate in a courtroom
would reveal State secrets and damage
National Security in a sworn declaration
Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
insisted that quote disclosure of
whether or not lethal Force has been
authorized to combat a terrorist
organization overseas and if so the
specific targets of such action would
provide the nation's enemies with
critical information needed to evade
hostile action this was head spinning if
it was true
it was quite obviously the
administration's leaks and not our
lawsuit that had created that Danger
this pattern
placing information into the public
sphere
and then claiming secrecy when faced
with legal challenge is an all too
common feature of National Security Law
and practice in February of 2008 I was
in a federal court in San Jose
California arguing against the dismissal
of a lawsuit brought by five victims of
the cia's rendition and torture program
the basis for the government's motion to
dismiss was a sworn declaration by CIA
director Michael Hayden insisting that
any confirmation or denial of the
lawsuit's allegations would disclose
State secrets and damage National
Security on that very same day
Hayden himself was testifying before
Congress and disclosing officially for
the first time that the CIA had
waterboarded three prisoners
I should add just two months before that
Hayden had written in a letter to CIA
employees that the CIA had destroyed 92
videotapes depicting enhanced
interrogation techniques because the CIA
had determined that they were not
relevant to any Congressional or
judicial proceeding this is the
expertise to which courts obligingly
defer
the government's legal fictions around
secrecy can produce some amusing results
in November of 2010 Wikileaks and its
Media Partners began publishing a
quarter of a million confidential State
Department cables that they had obtained
from army private Chelsea Manning
hundreds of thousands of government
employees and contractors were
immediately warned by their superiors
not to view the cables even those
published in full by the New York Times
and other media Outlets because they
might lack the proper clearance to do so
I was under no such injunction and I
found some pretty interesting cables
describing the Diplomatic Fallout from
the cia's rendition and torture programs
from Guantanamo and from drone strikes
in 2011 the ACLU submitted a foia
request to the state department for 23
of those cables there was an element of
Mischief in this request it was the
first and only time we had used the foia
to ask for documents that we literally
already held
in our hand but we were curious what
would the state department do
would they continue to withhold the
cables in full
with a bow to reality and declassify
them or would they process the request
by redacting what they deem sensitive
and releasing the rest
if you chose option C hats off to you
sure enough the state department sent us
redacted versions of 11 of the cables
offering a rare road map of their
classification process
the ACLU created a web feature that
allowed readers to hover the mouse over
the redacted portions to see exactly
what had been removed
this included to reference included a
reference to allegations of Italian
prosecutors that a U.S military jet had
traversed Swiss airspace on the day that
the CIA kidnapped cleric Abu Omar from
Milan that was no secret
two years earlier an Italian Court had
convicted an Absentia 23 Americans most
of them CIA operatives for their role in
his abduction and rendition to Egypt
where he was tortured
also redacted was a cable describing the
pressure the U.S had placed on Germany
to shut down a criminal investigation
into the cia's kidnapping of Khalid
al-masri
and another explaining how the Abu grave
torture Scandal had made the U.S less
secure
I called this result amusing
but in secrecy disputes the government
gets the last laugh
we argued in court that by processing
our foia requests
the government had acknowledged that the
cables were authentic
that meant or should have meant that the
state department could no longer hang
its hat on the distinction between what
was known and what was confirmed and
should now be compelled to declassify
the cables in full but a federal court
sided with the government
because our foia request had listed the
cables by date and number
and had not specifically mentioned
Wikileaks the state department had
actually admitted Nothing by processing
our request they might be different
cables altogether
of course the court could reach this
embarrassing conclusion only by refusing
to take 30 seconds to look at the cables
published by wikiweeks and those held by
the government side by side
John Brennan's cheeky refusal to
acknowledge the cia's Drone program was
a hit at Harvard
the academic audience appreciated being
in on the joke
but the game the government plays in
these cases is corrosive and damaging
by deploying selective leaks to the
press and secrecy claims to the courts
The Government Can simultaneously
manipulate public debate and avoid
accountability and oversight
and of course the flip side of impunity
for insiders is strict liability for
dissenters
the Espionage Act of 1917 the principal
vehicle for prosecuting National
Security links leaks does not
distinguish between unauthorized leaks
to the press in the public interest and
the sale of secrets to foreign enemies
which is to say it doesn't distinguish
between sources and spies
in fact in a recent leaked prosecution
the Department of Justice took the
remarkable position that unauthorized
leaks to the Press were more pernicious
than the typical Espionage case where a
spy sells classified information for
money because when information appears
in the Press every foreign adversary and
not just one stood to benefit
all too often National Security Elites
regard the American public as their
adversaries and place their own
interests ahead of the values of an open
Society
it's understandable that in the
immediate aftermath of a national trauma
like 911 courts would give the executive
branch a longer leash on matters of
National Security
well it's harder to explain is how this
excessive judicial deference amounting
to de facto impunity has endured and
entrenched itself
over time
in a speech at Hebrew University in
Jerusalem in 1987 the late Justice
William Brennan lamented the shabby
treatment civil liberties have received
in the United States in times of war or
perceived threats to National Security
he described a cyclical pattern
in an atmosphere of Crisis courts would
be in his words reluctant to question
the factual bases underlying asserted
security threats
and would defer to Executive demands
that Liberties be temporarily curtailed
after each perceived security crisis
ended Brennan observed the United States
has remorsefully realized that the
abrogation of civil liberties was
unnecessary and the claim dangers wildly
exaggerated
quote the rumors of French Intrigue
during the 1790s the claims that
civilian courts were unable to
adjudicate the allegedly treasonous
actions of Northerners during the Civil
War the hysterical belief that criticism
of conscription and the war effort might
lead droves of soldiers to Desert the
army or resist the draft during World
War One the wild assertions of sabotage
or Espionage by Japanese Americans
during World War II and the paranoid
fear that the American Communist Party
stood ready to overthrow the government
were all so baseless that they would be
comical were it not for the serious
hardship that they caused during the
time of Crisis Brennan noted
nevertheless the country had proved
unable to break this cycle because
Brennan believed the crises were too
infrequent and the country too tranquil
for courts to develop the expertise to
scrutinize claimed threats
quote a jurisprudence capable of braving
the overblown claims of national
security must be forged in times of
Crisis by the sort of intimate
familiarity with National Security
threats that tests their bases in fact
explores their relation to the exercise
of civil freedoms and probes the limits
of their Compass he insisted
in this way he hoped adversity could be
the handmaiden of Liberty
if Justice Brennan had been correct
if courts simply needed more exposure to
National Security claims to develop the
institutional capability to assess them
the last two decades should have
provided it
but it now seems clear that Justice
Brennan's optimism was misplaced
have courts learned to test the factual
bases of claim National Security threats
to the contrary they've doubled down on
a doctrine of deference that insists on
their own institutional incompetence to
second-guess security officials
have courts explored the relation of
asserted threats to the exercise of
civil freedoms to the contrary they've
treated National Security interests as
absolute and resisted a jurisprudence of
proportionality that would contextualize
threats
and way competing values have courts
probed the limits of the compass of the
government's claims of crisis
to the contrary they've acquiesced to a
definition of Crisis wholly lacking in
temporal or Geographic constraints a
conflict that takes takes place
everywhere
and forever
Justice Brennan assumed that National
crises would be defined or at least
Define a bull
he had in mind Wars or conflicts of
fixed duration and scope
the post-9 11 National Security project
with its focus on countering terrorist
threats has in the words of one scholar
identified the perfect conceptual
vehicle for a permanent mobilization of
the security state
and National Security Law in the age of
counterterrorism has made judicial
abdication not the cyclical exception
that Justice Brennan described but an
entrenched Norm that John Brennan no
doubt prefers
that courts have embraced this
diminished role and if anything deepened
their commitment to deference despite
the absence of a major terrorist attack
on U.S oil since 9 11. is a testament to
the success of National Security Elites
in enshrining into law a permanent
state of exception
what is National Security
the term is overused and under analyzed
and it's so rotely entoned in so many
contexts that it's been drained of
almost all meaning
in his Memoir Graham green tells the
story of a friend who at her father's
funeral is urged by an elderly priest to
return to the church
remind me she asked the priests what are
the arguments for the existence of God
I knew them once replies the priest but
I've forgotten them
there's something similarly ritualistic
in the way we invoke National Security
without attending to the meaning of the
words or to what they do or don't
encompass
Victor klemper are in a much darker
context described how words idioms and
sentence structures can be imposed on a
people in a million repetitions and
taken on board mechanically and
unconsciously and klemper is
understanding the process as a closed
system for undermining meaning by
forcing a public debate using words and
even categories of its own invention a
government can manufacture consent
through the manufacture of language the
Press merely by doing its job amplifies
the new terminology even if it does so
critically it writes the concept into
being
National Security has entered our
Collective bloodstream through these
endless repetitions and has enshrined
itself as a defining National interest
without being clearly defined I don't
mean to suggest that the law provides no
definitions there are many
but over time the definitional scope of
national security has been continually
revised and expanded to include other
recapitulated terminology like Homeland
Security
or or counter-terrorism
National Security is now understood to
Encompass National Defense functions on
one side and domestic law enforcement
functions on the other
with few if any limiting principles and
because national security law came into
being in the Cold War context of an
existential nuclear threat
once we place the National Security
label on a government function a
distinct set of rules and expectations
comes with it for example we've long
understood that in our constitutional
system even murder suspects must walk
free if police or prosecutors break the
rules
but when the context is National
Security our risk tolerance evaporates
and we conjure a new category of people
who cannot be released even to enforce
fundamental rights or vindicate core
values the Guantanamo prison remains
open in part because during the brief
window when the Obama Administration
could have emptied it its own
inter-agency task force concluded that
48 of the prisoners could neither be
prosecuted nor released
they couldn't be prosecuted the task
force candidly stated either because
there was insufficient admissible
evidence of guilt meaning evidence that
had not been beaten out of them
or because their conduct did not
constitute a chargeable offense meaning
they had committed no crime
and they couldn't be released in the
task Force's words because they posed a
national security threat that cannot be
sufficiently mitigated through feasible
and appropriate security measures what
does that sentence mean
my question is sincere not rhetorical
cannot be released in what sense why do
we casually accept the assertion that
the release of any individual any 50
individuals poses a national security
threat that requires indefinite
detention by the most powerful military
in human history
what kind of threat
is our Global surveillance apparatus
incapable of keeping an eye on a few
dozen people who have been in our
custody for a decade now two
does the risk that some might rejoin the
Taliban or even Al-Qaeda create so great
a danger that we have no reasonable
alternative to locking them away forever
in short why isn't a statement like this
greeted with incredulity
even mockery
to be sure the decision to continue the
Guantanamo indefinite detention regime
has drawn considerable criticism
including from the legal Academy that
criticism has rightly taken issue with
the legal basis for prolonged attention
and has challenged the assertion that
the military response authorized by
Congress in the aftermath of 9 11
includes the authority to hold people
forever or until terrorism has been
defeated whichever comes first
you can laugh
but we rarely hear criticism of the
childish premise that Terror suspects
are super villains who will scatter
death like dandelion seeds if sprung
from their cages you're far more likely
to hear a Guantanamo opponents insist
that in no conceivable scenario will Abu
zubaida be allowed to walk the streets
of Chicago if he can't be convicted in a
federal court he'll be put in
Immigration detention and deported
immediately this mode of argument has
surely been strategic I've used it
myself
but I've come to regard it as misguided
by not objecting to the hyperbolic
threat inflation that's deployed to
justify Lawless actions by not insisting
on a taxonomy of National Security
threats that distinguishes the
existential from the routine
we drastically narrow the range of
options that are deemed reasonable by
the public policy makers and ultimately
the courts
we get trapped in that claustrophobic
fallacy familiar to anyone who opposed
the invasion of Iraq 20 years ago this
month
but what would you do about saddam's
weapons of mass destruction
a few years ago I pulled into an Upstate
rest area on the New York State Thruway
on a quiet Summer Afternoon
and picked up a brochure from an
information kiosk published by a state
law enforcement agency it was headlined
know the eight signs of terrorism
and it urged the public to be vigilant
for Telltale indicators
be on the lookout for people who are
taking pictures
or making drawings
watch for people who are in places they
should not be and people who don't fit
into the daily routine of your community
be especially on guard for the dry run
described as putting people into
position and moving them around without
actually committing a terrorist attack
a quick internet search reveals that
versions of this document Our
Generations Duck and Cover have been
republished and distributed by law
enforcement agencies across the country
Americans everywhere it would seem are
being enlisted to conjure dark fantasies
from routine observations
my sense is that documents like these
are aimed not only at the public but at
the police the state and local law
enforcement agencies that long to be
part of the action the cops on the beat
who are invited to identify as Warriors
in the great struggle
not only in Manhattan and Los Angeles
but in police departments Nationwide
suburban and Rural officers are sitting
in training rooms looking at slide Decks
that depict ordinary American scenes and
being initiated into the apparitional
world of counter-terrorism
another kind of threat Conjuring took
place in Hollywood soon after the 9 11
attacks as described breathlessly in the
Hollywood Insider publication the rap
a lot of what transpired that night is
still top secret but this much we do
know
one evening in October 2001 just weeks
after Al Qaeda terrorists took down the
Twin Towers in Manhattan and maimed the
Pentagon a group of about 30 of
Hollywood's top creatives a-listers like
Oliver Stone Law and Order Producer Dick
Wolf seven director David Fincher NYPD
Blues David milch and the late John
Singleton to name just a few
we're quietly invited to mingle with
high-level members of the U.S military
the group was officially though secretly
named the entertainment industry task
force and its Mission which everyone
accepted
was to help America prevent another 911
by brainstorming terrorist scenarios so
out of the box crazy they could only
happen in the movies unless that is Al
Qaeda thought of them first
the first meeting began at around 7 pm
and didn't break up until sometime
before midnight attendees had so many
horrifyingly destructive and diabolical
ideas they decided to meet again a few
weeks later for a second session all
assigned non-disclosure agreements
swearing them to secrecy and while they
were Whispers in Hollywood newsrooms
about some sort of hush-hush summit
nobody will have to work
I want to believe that this wasn't
serious
that the high-level military officials
saw an excuse to mingle with celebrities
that Hollywood's overgrown man children
got their chance to play act initiation
into the world of covert operations
that the memo that was produced from
these meetings was quietly placed in a
Dusty file cabinet No Doubt with top
secret stamped on every page
I want to believe that
but I remember too well the years of
Relentless color-coded threat warning
based on chatter about impending attacks
the announcements made with great
Fanfare that ludicrous plots had been
disrupted a dirty bomber whose plan was
to place uranium in a bucket and swing
it around his body to create a
centrifuge
a clownish conspiracy to topple the
Sears Tower into Lake Michigan to create
a tsunami
Vice President Dick Cheney described
that last one as a very real threat
key ingredient in the shrill
fear-mongering that has characterized
the post-911 security regime is a deep
desire on the part of its participants
to identify as actors in an epical event
one could fairly describe this as a form
of identity politics
as George Packer wrote a decade after 9
11 with perhaps some measure of Maya
culpa
at the time of the attacks few educated
Americans born after 1950 had any direct
experience of war or persecution or
cataclysmic failure after 9 11 this Gap
in the resumes of intellectuals gave
them both a sense of inadequacy
an outbreak of Envy for the greatest
generation and a compensatory tendency
to inflate the drama of the war on
terror and their own role in it
in a lecture in this room six years ago
I discussed the way the identity needs
of these would-be Warriors have created
an inverted politics of National
Security
those who Proclaim that today's
terrorists represent an unprecedented
threat to our way of life that our
existing laws courts and institutions
even our prisons are inadequate in the
face of this threat that we have no
choice but to dispense with core
principles including even the
prohibition Against torture to defeat
this ruthless enemy that in short 9 11
changed everything
it is these fantasists who are extolled
as hard-nosed realists the Warriors who
are willing to take the gloves off
by contrast those who die who defend the
vitality and viability of our
constitutional system who insist that
our existing institutions are equal to
the challenges posed by transnational
terrorism who demand that we abide by
core commitments including Fair trials
for and Humane treatment of prisoners it
is these cool-headed unpanicked persons
who are dismissed as weak and naive
afflicted by a pre-911 mindset
that distorted worldview allows the
Judiciary to view its own abdication of
oversight as an expression of solidarity
solidarity with the strong and the wise
rather than professional weakness
in case after case I and my colleagues
encountered federal judges who were
astonished sometimes even angered by our
suggestion that they carefully
scrutinize the claims of National
Security officials
one case stands out
my ACLU my ACLU colleagues challenged
the constitutionality of a law that
authorized the government to monitor
Americans international phone calls and
emails on mass so long as the targets of
the surveillance were not U.S persons
and were reasonably believed to be
outside the United States
the plaintiffs were lawyers journalists
human rights researchers and others
whose Communications were very likely to
be swept up under the law and who had
been compelled to take burdensome steps
to protect the confidentiality of
sensitive information
naturally the question before the courts
was not whether the Constitution
permitted his Mass surveillance program
but whether our plaintiffs were
permitted to challenge it
the government moved for summary
judgment on the ground that plaintiffs
lacked standing because they couldn't
show that their own Communications had
been surveilled this is a standard
Catch-22 in challenges to national
security surveillance laws even if the
Law's scope is public its specific
targets are secret so the government can
prevent any plaintiff from testing its
constitutionality
a federal district judge agreed with the
government
but a three-judge panel of the second
Circuit Court of Appeals including
Yale's own Guido Calabrese reversed
holding that the plaintiffs had
demonstrated a reasonable fear that
their Communications would be monitored
which was sufficient to establish
standing
the full second circuit then split six
to six on the question with six judges
agreeing that our case could go forward
and the other six siding with the
government
judge Dennis Jacobs joined his
colleagues who believe the lawsuit
should be dismissed but he wrote
separately to convey just how offended
he was at being asked to decide
the lawsuit's allegations were
inadequate implausible and illusory he
wrote the challenged law concerned only
the surveillance of persons abroad who
are not United States citizens or
residents so the claim that plaintiffs
might be implicated quote Bear's
similarity to a pro-say plaintiff's
allegation that the CIA is controlling
him through a radio embedded in his
molar at the risk of being obvious he
continued the purpose of this lawsuit is
litigation for its own sake
for these lawyers to claim a role in
policy making for which they were not
appointed or elected for which they are
not fitted by experience and for which
they are not accountable
as best I can see the only purpose of
this litigation is for counsel and
plaintiffs to act out their fantasy of
persecution to validate their
pretensions to policy expertise to make
themselves consequential rather than
marginal and to raise funds for
self-sustaining litigation in short
councils and plaintiff's only
perceptible interest is to carve out for
themselves and influence over government
policy and interest that the law of
standing forecloses
two things are striking about this
tirade
the first is that the lawyers were not
claiming a role for themselves they were
trying to claim a role for judge Jacobs
Congress had enacted a law the president
had signed it and asking a court to
determine whether the political branches
had overstepped constitutional
boundaries the ACLU was not usurping a
policy-making role we were invoking a
Judicial one
the second is that the ACLU in our
plaintiffs were right and judge Jacob's
quite wrong about the law in question
we did not learn this through the
litigation of course
the Supreme Court sided with judge
Jacobs ending the case before it could
begin
we learned it through a spectacular Act
of law breaking
when Edward Snowden shared classified
documents with journalists
it turned out that under the putative
authority of the challenge law the NSA
had engaged in what it calls Upstream
surveillance which involves placing
surveillance equipment on the internet
Central arteries and systematically
intercepting and copying private email
messages
phone calls and other data flowing in
and out of the country and then
searching that data with thousands of
keywords that are never approved by any
judge
even the government's more targeted use
of the law to obtain the communications
of specific foreigners swept up the
communications of many Americans in July
of 2014 the Washington Report Washington
Post published a deeply reported
investigation into surveillance under
the 2008 law based on a cache of 160 000
intercepted Communications
ordinary internet users far outnumber
legally targeted foreigners the post
revealed and nearly half of the
surveillance files a strikingly high
proportion contain names email addresses
or other details that the NSA marked as
belonging to U.S citizens or residents
our plaintiff's allegations were very
far from implausible we strongly
suspected but could not know that at the
time but some observers knew
one of them was Edward Snowden
who saw the Supreme Court's dismissal of
our case on justiceability grounds as a
final piece of evidence that National
Security checks and balances were broken
less than three months later
he walked out of an NSA facility in
Hawaii carrying the evidence that courts
had refused to look at
the irony
is that had the federal court staying to
consider our claims
rather than dismiss them without
adjudication they might have prevented
the most consequential unauthorized leak
in the nation's history
in June of 2013 when the guardian and
Washington Post published their first
Blockbuster stories based on documents
provided by Edward Snowden President
Obama responded testily the newly
disclosed surveillance programs
including the Revelation that the
government was collecting metadata from
virtually all U.S phone calls on an
ongoing daily basis
should be of no concern to Americans
because the president insisted they were
conducted under very strict supervision
by all three branches of government
we've got Congressional oversight and
judicial oversight he said and if people
can't trust not only the executive
branch but also don't trust Congress and
don't trust federal judges to make sure
that we're abiding by the Constitution
due process and rule of law then we're
going to have some problems here
the president's claim that all three
branches of government were involved in
monitoring the surveillance activities
was generally accurate but far from
being a defense it would prove to be a
deep source of embarrassment for anyone
who had argued that legal oversight of
National Security Programs was
functional and effective
that's because the activities that had
been approved in secret failed to
survive public scrutiny
stung by sunlight all three branches of
government felt compelled to change
course sometimes dramatically the
president appointed a panel of senior
intelligence officials and legal experts
to conduct a comprehensive review of
intelligent surveillance practices and
the panel recommended 46 sweeping
reforms some of which were adopted just
months after the president's remarks
for the first and only time in my two
decades at the ACLU the federal courts
did not dismiss our lawsuit challenging
the legality of an intelligent
surveillance program on standing or
secrecy grounds instead the second
Circuit Court of Appeals ruled that the
nsa's mass collection of Americans fall
record call records was illegal and had
always been illegal
and for the first time since the 1970s
Congress enacted a legislation that
reduced rather than expanded the
surveillance authorities of the
intelligence community no one has
plausibly argued that any of these
reforms would have occurred if Snowden
had not shared classified documents with
the Press I think some of the
condescension and disdain with which
Snowden is viewed in National Security
circles is attributable to the awkward
fact that the only significant reforms
to intelligence surveillance laws in
modern American history have been
initiated by leaks and law breaking not
by the system's supposedly rigorous
checks and balances that's why I have
little patience for those who scold that
Snowden should have raised his concerns
through the system what system do people
think they're talking about
what's the proper channel for reporting
that the intelligence Community
developed and deployed a global Mass
surveillance system with a blessing of
all three branches of government but
without public consultation
the truth is that Snowden did vastly
more to reform intelligent surveillance
practices by breaking the law then I and
my colleagues did by requesting politely
that courts enforce it
I regard this as a very grave indictment
of National Security Law and practice
is it also an indictment of public
interest litigation aimed at
constraining National Security abuses
albeit quite a different one than judge
Jacobs offered
did all of this failed litigation all of
these dismissals on justiceability
grounds unwittingly enhance The Prestige
of the system and help reify the status
of National Security Law
there's no question that I and my
colleagues were actors in this theater
of law
and no one and one could reasonably
argue that our participation conferred
undeserved legitimacy on the whole
sorted charade
Yale's estimable Sam Owen who was with
us tonight has offered a different
version of that argument suggesting that
the litigation I've described had the
effect of making the US's Global warm or
sanitized
and thereby more sustainable
instead of litigating to challenge the
legality of War we chose to in moin's
words defend the rights of those swept
up and in so doing may have laundered
the inhumanity from what began as a
brutal Enterprise by helping to recodify
a war that thus became endless legal
and humane
in general I find any suggestion that my
time could have been better spent almost
irresistibly compelling
[Laughter]
while much of our litigation did in fact
challenge the ward Paradigm I am not
here to argue that the cases I brought
and the causes I championed materially
changed the world for the better
still what I find confounding about
moyne's argument is the suggestion that
the decisions of a handful of human
rights lawyers had any geopolitical
significance and the implication that
had we devoted our energies elsewhere or
nowhere
the course of the Forever War might have
been altered or it's foreverness
foreshortened
whether public interest litigation after
9 11 did more to legitimize or
delegitimize national security law and
the war on terror will depend on the
final analysis on whether and how the
legal Community including the legal
Academy responds to the record of
impunity I've laid out here
will it continue to confer Prestige and
dignity on a regime the team's
non-justiciable some of the most vital
questions concerning the relationship
between state power and individual
rights
or might the embarrassments of these
last two decades compel the emergence of
competing Norms that bring some measure
of democratic accountability into this
place of exception what were those Norms
look like
first and foremost
the doctrine of judicial deference to
executive branch expertise has slipped
its Moorings and is now deployed not to
respect separation of powers
but to erode them
the notion that courts are incompetent
but the CIA is competent has always
struck me as odd but even if there are
appropriately cabin instances where
deference is warranted its judges not
leaders of spy agencies who possess the
institutional competence to weigh
competing interests
Court should be especially on guard for
the structural conflicts of interest
that arise when the putative expert also
represents the entity accused of
wrongdoing
in those instances courts would do
better to begin with the assumption that
the executive is not credible
some years ago I was invited to share a
stage at a Judicial conference with the
late John Rizzo who had been the cia's
acting general counsel during the post-9
11 torture conspiracy the moderator of
our polite debate was none other than
judge Dennis Jacobs who is more gracious
in person than in print
I don't remember much about the event
itself but I spent a fair amount of time
with John Rizzo over that weekend as he
smoked cigars at an outdoor picnic table
and held forth on the political and
intelligence leaders he'd cross paths
with during 34 years at the CIA
this one was good for the agency that
one hung us out to dry this other one
was very good for the agency the man
unapologetically divided the world into
two camps that's understandable
he didn't want his friends to go to
prison or have their careers derailed
we'd be naive to expect otherwise but
why in the world would we want judges to
defer to someone like this if John Rizzo
was an expert in anything it was in
keeping himself and his people out of
legal and political trouble
all too often demands for deference have
nothing to do with expertise rather
their demands that courts treat National
Security claims as absolute
if the CIA director insists that
allowing a torture victim his day in
court will complicate the agency's
relationship with a foreign intelligence
service
how that interest should be balanced
against other important interests such
as providing a remedy for an abuse
victim or ensuring accountability for
misconduct or resolving a consequential
legal question is quintessentially a
Judicial function not a security
function if courts refuse under the
banner of deference to claim that role
National Security officials will
continue to be the expert architects of
their own impunity
the uses and misuses of secrecy which
I've spoken about at length these last
two days present A distinct but related
challenge
as we've discussed the government
routinely invokes secrecy doctrines to
shield from legal scrutiny activities
that are not Secret at all the so-called
official acknowledgment Doctrine which
holds that even public information is
treated a secret so long as the
government chooses not to confirm it has
become an insurmountable liability
Shield
this is a this is an accountability
crisis of the Court's own making
and the solution is straightforward
courts should stop treating the
government's asserted interests as an
All or Nothing proposition
they can accept that there may be
situations in which official
confirmation of known facts creates a
distinct harm but not accept that the
judicial inquiry ends there if core
values are at stake in other words they
can introduce proportionality analysis
which is very common in other
jurisdictions but has been completely
alien to U.S national security law and
practice
even when secrets are still actually
secret courts have a vital role
for reasons that should be obvious
excessive deference to executive branch
classification decisions threatens any
theory of democratic governance if the
president and his designees have
complete control over the information by
which we can judge their actions then
the public can neither consent to nor
hold leaders accountable for actions
undertaken in our name
at oral argument in the foia case I
discussed yesterday one judge challenged
me to cite prior cases in which courts
had overridden executive branch
classification decisions in National
Security litigation I could not get past
the fingers on my first hand
it's not hard to understand judge's
reluctance when an executive branch
Security offers officer shows up in
their Chambers with a briefcase handcase
handcuffed to his wrist and delivers a
classified affidavit from the director
of Central Intelligence attesting to the
glaciers that will melt and the oceans
that will boil off if a case is allowed
to go forward very rarely will a judge
be inclined to dig any deeper
but they should dig deeper
and they should consider these claims
against the backdrop of a long history
of gross exaggerations and outright
deceptions
and they should do so with confidence
the only people whose security is likely
to be jeopardized are those who misuse
secrecy to conceal misconduct
none of these changes in judicial
Behavior are likely to occur absent to
broader societal shift towards
resilience
we've allowed rhetorical excesses about
a war on terrorism to obscure the
distinction between acceptable and
unacceptable risks
Justice Brennan hoped that judges would
develop the capacity to make those
distinctions but judges are far more
likely to reflect society's relationship
to risk than to guide it
the amorphous term National Security
which we apply indiscriminately to
efforts to prevent nuclear proliferation
on the one hand
and the arrest of inept Knuckleheads
attract entrapped by FBI informants into
implausible terrorist plots on the other
hand isn't helpful
the former is a legitimate matter of
National Defense
the latter should not be regarded as a
matter of any national importance much
less National Security we should scorn
rather than a grandize political leaders
who refuse to acknowledge that
distinction and who equate the danger of
terrorism with world wars in which
millions of lives were extinguished or a
cold war in which billions lived under
threat of annihilation
my sense is that most Americans
spend very little time thinking about
terrorism
and that institutional incentives not
public fears best account for how the
most secure Society in human history is
kept in a state of legal emergency
those incentives will be difficult to
disrupt but we have to start somewhere
and if any institution should be at the
Forefront of reasserting some sense of
moral Poise rather than panic in the
face of ineradicable but non-existential
threats it's the legal Academy
for all the ways in which the 9 11
attacks reshaped our law and
institutions
the silence and shade that still
surround our efforts to bring the
alleged perpetrators to Justice are
truly remarkable
this is the signal embarrassment of
national security law that in the 20 odd
years since the attacks the U.S has
managed to invade two countries and send
our military into many others to
construct and then dismantle a secret
Global detention apparatus to develop
and deploy systems of mass surveillance
to create new domestic security agencies
but has failed even to begin the trial
of the five alleged perpetrators who
have been in our custody for two decades
this might make an ideal starting point
for a course on National Security Law
one that could not be taught in a single
sentence
the course could explore how grave
misjudgments become self-fulfilling
prophecies through a kind of bad faith
syllogism
first we decide that our existing laws
and institutions cannot
that's okay
first we decide that our existing laws
and institutions can't accommodate the
detention interrogation and trial of
these prisoners so new rules are needed
next we subject the prisoners to such
appalling mistreatment that convictions
under our existing laws May in fact
be impracticable but because we won't
release them under any circumstances we
now need new rules that will allow us to
adjudicate their crimes against us while
suppressing our crimes against them
that these new rules constitute a moral
practical and legal disaster that have
caused Decades of delays is almost
beside the point to their proponents the
point of the rules was impunity for the
rulemakers and it's precisely that
impunity that will make this Paradigm so
difficult to dislodge
if we're going to be stuck in this
paradigm as it appears we will be for
some time
let's at least insist on a definition of
national security that encompasses more
than the never-ending menu of threats
against us
let's agree that A system that deems the
perpetrators of grave abuses above the
law and the victims of those abuses
beneath it should not be called secure
and what's resolve that the security of
senior officials The Architects and
beneficiaries of the states of exception
will no longer be attained at the
expense of the security of our laws and
values
thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
thank you so much
um I'm wondering
uh nice to be back I'm wondering
um how you see the National Security
regime as you call it as having changed
at all it seems our political leaders
have sort of moved on at least
rhetorically from the war on terror
um so have you seen any sort of
developments in this National Security
regime yeah I mean one of the cases that
thank you for that question one of the
cases that I discussed yesterday was so
strange because it was 2021 or 2022 and
the Supreme Court was talking about Abu
zubaida and it was like well we're still
talking about this and we're still
saying that what happened to Abu zubaida
in 2002 or 2003 that everyone knows as a
state secret so in one sense the system
has not moved on in another sense
um uh you know I said yesterday that
this system is adept at identifying new
hosts
um I I think sort of seeing the pivot
that the National Security set has made
um you know to being self-style
Defenders of democracy
um uh in response to
Russian propaganda for example you know
now you have the war in Ukraine
um it the whole cyber security issue
writ large there's always an effort to
you know identify something that will
continue to justify the massive budgets
and authorities and that will require
the secrecy that is the Keystone for
that impunity so I agree with you that
there's not as much conversation about
terrorism in part because we haven't had
much terrorism here and most Americans
are not talking about that but um but
you certainly have not seen any
reduction in the budgets of the agencies
that were created
um to to take this on or really any
crack in the wall of the kind of legal
black hole that the system represents
foreign
so thank you that was great hi
um I guess I had a similar question
which is to ask you to do a little bit
of forecasting for us so since the years
that you and I litigated together I've
done
um
more work at the international sort of
level and something that's really
striking is that the U.S creates
Frameworks and in this case plausible
deniability that of course then becomes
a model for many many other governments
and you know in other places
El Salvador being a notable example the
National Security framework now is being
used to go after street level gang
leaders so I'm just curious if from your
review that you know you talked about it
being a
sort of a paradigm that is able to find
many ghosts but uh hosts but I hope that
you could just say a little bit more
about that yeah and whether and sorry
and I guess just relatedly whether you
think that that potentially is a way in
which the politics around this change
because one of the problems
in terms of mobilizing support for doing
the kind of challenges that we've tried
to do is the fact that the people were
not only despised but they had no
political constituency within this
country
yeah and so you know as you know I went
from representing torture victims and
torture cases where basically everybody
agreed every reasonable person agreed it
was a problem but didn't think it had
any connection to them to working on
issues of mass surveillance where most
people didn't think it was a problem but
they all realized it was connected to
them in some way right um but but there
there was an opportunity I mean you know
you did have significant political
majorities that were not partisan
majorities that were pretty
uncomfortable with the revelations that
came out of this known regime I mean the
reason why the branches of government
changed course was because the public
wanted that change so I do think that
you know to the extent that the
government abuses touch more people they
create more opportunities to change the
political discourse you know sort of
looking overseas I would just say I mean
as you remember there were clients who
we represented together who were
citizens of other countries the U.S got
our cases dismissed on the ground that
it would complicate their relationship
with those kind countries meanwhile the
courts in those countries gave remedies
to our clients right and so and used
other kinds of analysis and you know
even if they didn't want to litigate the
cases and expose their official Secrets
they realized that that meant they
should pay the victims and not
um you know have this incentive where
they simultaneously get to claim secrecy
and toss the victim out of court so I I
um
you know one of the very frustrating
things about you know doing human rights
work in a U.S framework is how little
interest
um you know U.S courts have in being in
conversation with courts and other
democracies that face greater terrorism
threats than we do and yet find a way to
adjudicate some of these same kinds of
disputes
foreign
totally brilliant talk
um so well delivered
um I I just want to you know hear more
about uh Edward Snowden because I I
totally accept your critique of me but
it seemed like you you accepted like a
deep self-critique in addressing what
Edward Snowden got wrong so I guess I'm
a little what he got wrong what he got
right what he got right sorry yeah so I
accept the self-critique I'm really good
at yeah so I just want I'm just trying
to understand the kind of credible
Pathway to political change in the
situation because you've said
the judges we we spent you know decades
were still doing it asking judges for
change which they will never deliver at
the same time you engage in a lot of
idealization of the Constitution itself
of the legal system uh and that's part
part of your shtick uh even as you
acknowledge that they're the problem
uh and and then Snowden makes more
change than legal activism ever does by
breaking the law so I I guess I don't
understand what what the political move
is it's a it's a great question and it
is a paradox because the way that
Snowden creates change is by breaking
the law and thereby reinvigorating legal
and Democratic oversight we basically
only get energetic oversight judicial or
legislative in response to leaks and law
breaking the whole modern apparatus of
intelligence surveillance uh oversight
was a result of the church committee
which was a result of a bunch of
anti-war activists breaking into an FBI
field office outside of Philadelphia
stealing all the files and mailing them
to Betty Metzger at the Washington Post
right so like basically and and all of
the
um you know sort of limited successes
that we've had over the last decade you
can trace to someone inside the system
um deciding that the public had a need
to see something and then once the
public has that information I think
lawyers and even litigators are actors
in that right so we did file a
successful lawsuit based on documents
that Snowden gave us it turned out that
even our unsuccessful lawsuit was a
critical piece of bringing him forward
and I know not from Snowden but from
journalists who got his documents but
there were subfolders in what he gave
them that were marked for the ACLU
um so so that kind of conversation goes
on as well but yeah I I I take your
point that there is
um a you know tension between my uh
disparagement of the system and my
aggrandizement of how it should be
um and
um I can see that it's under theorized
okay
I might just mentioned that the Pentagon
papers yes or another example the
Pentagon papers are another example
where there was an illegal release been
printed in the New York Times and uh
which had a profound impact on the
resolution of the Vietnamese uh war and
so forth so yeah interestingly Dan
Ellsberg thinks it didn't he thinks he
was years too late he may have been
years too late but there's no question
that yeah well there's other parallels
which is that the you know Nixon White
House claimed that Ellsberg had
delivered a set of the Pentagon papers
to the Soviet
consulate or Embassy in DC he was viewed
as a spy and a Trader
um uh that was one of the cases that I
could put on my one hand where a court
actually said in the face of a
government secrecy claim no you haven't
showed us enough for us to give you this
injunction and it's a good thing they
did I mentioned this last night
um but you know 10 years after the
government lost that case in the Supreme
Court the solicitor general at the time
Roman Griswold wrote an op-ed saying
Secret's not worth keeping he said in
the decade that had passed he had never
seen a shred of evidence that anything
in the Pentagon papers caused any harm
to National Security had I never seen
anybody suggest that it had and that's
why I say that kind of context has to be
part of Court's consideration of
government secrecy claims because it
cost the government nothing to invoke
secrecy doctrines to protect
embarrassment
thank you for your talk
um
I wanted to ask if the ACLU has heard
about and if so are they looking into
the following two allegations one is
that the Iranian General who was
assassinated during the Trump
administration's tenure had been
attending a meeting to discuss
the peaceful negotiation of settlement
with Saudi Arabia about the war in Yemen
I mean that's one uh yeah I mean I could
send you the source and then the second
allegation is Seymour Hersh allegation
that U.S operatives
working in concert with no no way I
believe uh blew up the north stream to
pipeline that would have that was
supposedly done last year so I just
wanted to know if you were aware of this
okay yeah I'm I'm I'm aware of those
things as a citizen they don't fall
within my professional remit I work for
a domestic civil liberties organization
that does not concern itself with
explosions in Northern Waters or
that kind of military operation so I
don't have anything particular to share
with you there and it's not it's I think
the role of journalists not the role of
the ACLU to explore those allegations
further
thank you
um can I ask in your Ideal World what do
you imagine a sustainable like long-term
mechanism of accountability to look like
in the National Security space because
from your talk it sounds like currently
the only effective mechanism of
accountability is relying on people to
break the law like Snowden I mean it's
it's a it's a really hard question and I
always ask when people ask me this
question are you a computer scientist
um are you yeah because this is the this
is the conversation I have with Snowden
all the time he thinks that democracy is
a problem that can be solved because he
comes from a technical background and I
tell him that it's actually not a
solvable problem but but
um but just sort of let me give you an
example so the the last great
intelligence Scandal much bigger than
this note in Revelations in the 1970s
when we learned about the FBI's cointel
Pro program where they were sending
operatives into black student
organizations and the anti-war movement
breaking up marriages poison pan letters
they try to get Martin Luther King to
commit suicide all of this stuff comes
out and the congress's response is to do
three things two things really so first
they create the House and Senate
intelligence committees they decide that
congressional oversight isn't working we
need specialized committees that have
specialized access to classified
information we understand that the FBI
and the NSA and the CIA don't want to
share information with everyone in
Congress because it will weak out but
they can at least trust the you know the
10 people on each of these committees so
we're going to create these committees
the second thing they do is they create
the foreign intelligence surveillance
Court which can provide some judicial
oversight of you know domestic
intelligence surveillance not law
enforcement surveillance intelligence
surveillance and the interesting thing
is that the the key Insight of the
Snowden Revelations was that 50 years
later
those solutions to the 1970s problem
were no longer working
right the intelligence committees in
Congress had been set up to do extra
oversight it turns out they were extra
captured the people on those committees
were the closest ones to the
intelligence communities not the ones
who were scrutinizing it the most and
the court which had been created to
authorize individual intelligence
warrants which is an appropriate thing
to do in secret was instead writing 90
page opinions that were purporting to
authorize programmatic surveillance
including collecting metadata from every
American's phone call every day without
hearing any adversarial arguments from
people who might say that's not
constitutional and so the what was the
solution to the Snowden just well now
the foreign intelligence surveillance
Court can invite in expert adversaries
who will come in uh you know it's a
tweak that was made to that system I
don't have a structural solution here
right I don't think that the structure
is wrong you want an architecture that
divides power between different branches
of government but you need the
representatives of those branches of
government to take pride in that
Independence and not consider it I mean
the the dominant judicial doctrine in
National Security Law is deference
to the expertise of as I put it the very
perpetrators of these abuses themselves
and and that's not an acceptable mindset
for judges to bring I didn't come here
to talk to judges
um you know the much more modest goal
here is you know at least law schools
should think about what this body of law
is before they put it on a pedestal
thank you
hi thanks I wonder if you might share
any War stories about being surveilled
yourself either overtly or covertly in
different times during your work it
reminds me of a statement of Robert
Mueller when he was the FBI director I'm
most concerned about what we're not
hearing
no stories
if it's happening they're good at it
yeah
I think there was another question on
the back
the context of what we're talking about
the National Security day if
I I don't I don't I don't have an expert
answer to that question
yeah
here's what I will say that is not a
direct answer to your question
um that the reason why the passage of
new laws after 9 11 was so Swift is that
much of those laws had been written
before 9 11 and the laws that will be
passed after the next terrorist attack
have also already been written
some question in the corner
you know you played a pretty bleak
picture about what's happening and the
ways that that this whole National
Security Law is is corroding a lot of
our principles and I wonder if you could
just say a little more about the fisa
court itself which is an article 3 court
and therefore should should perform to
certain constitutional standards
and and how we have accountability for
the Judiciary which is normally through
Public Access and public oversight yeah
and and is this another example of
National Security concerns eroding our
institutions by undermining how our
article three courts work
yeah I mean if we start seeing more
courts adopt the same kind of secrecy
practices of the Fisk then for sure look
I mean what I said before
um I don't object to the existence of a
court that issues warrants in secret
even in public article three courts
warrants are issued in secret
right you don't send a note to someone
saying we're authorizing a wiretap
against you you should go at an ex parte
proceeding and a judge gives you a
warrant that's fine the problem with the
Fisk is Mission creep
um that I mean if if all the fisks were
doing were granting individualized
warrants at whatever the rate of
acceptance 99.9
um that would at least be performing you
know a function where we don't
traditionally rely on an adversarial
process or even a public process
although with warrants we do expect that
at some point they can be made public
after the investigation is over and you
know we've been fighting for years to
get the Fisk to do the same thing the
problem is when you have these broad
authorities that authorize the court to
issue broad programmatic warrants that
implicate constitutional rights and
there is no one in the room other than
the Department of Justice and the judge
to say wait a minute and so again one of
the post node and reforms is to give the
court at least the opportunity to have
an expert in the room who is not the
government but I think you know we need
to continue to push for the release of
their historical opinions on an ongoing
basis for the reason you identify
I mean this is another problem with
classification right even for that
absolutely minute category of
information that is properly classified
in the first instance almost none of it
should still be classified five years
later
right
um just a really wonderful talk and I
apologize for being so late
um the answer to your question was
provided before you arrived that's okay
yeah
um
yeah I struggle a little bit to figure
out how to ask us I have a tendency I
know to ask sort of for a prescriptive
conclusion
um and I'm going to try to avoid that
but
I feel like there's a way in which the
story you're telling is is generalizable
beyond the realm of National Security
and it seems like it's a story there's
kind of a triangle here between
legal means social movements
and in this case important acts of civil
disobedience
and as someone who's probably has less
faith in the power of love than someone
who teaches law ought to have I I guess
I do have a question about whether you
think there are lessons here about how
change comes about
and what role kind of relative role
those three
so to the extent we can call them three
separate actors are the kind of you guys
an elite legal institution trying to
bring about change broader social
movements who seem to be motivated on
the One Hand by the inculcation of fear
and on the other hand by the inculcation
of outrage when someone likes Stone can
bring it to their attention
and and whether that tells us anything
about how better to to hold State
accountable
yeah I I um I struggled with this
question and whether I should try
to come up with something more
prescriptive and hortatory at the end
and say you know other than just let's
change our values
um and and it's difficult
um especially for one of the reasons
that that hope suggested which is that
for a lot of what we're talking about
um the the victims are invisible and
abroad and so they're not going to be
victims around which we're going to
mobilize a movement the exception to
that might be when we're confronted with
horrific images of sexual abuse
and you know beatings and death at Abu
ghraib that can actually create some
kind of accountability moment but again
there you have it again there's someone
inside the system breaking the law in
order to put that in our faces and and
and to force that kind of response
um uh I I think there are things about
the security context
um where the politics are a little bit
unique you know as I described where
there's just no cost
um to saying we need I mean has there
ever been
in any democracy you know a good example
of a public punishing political leaders
for threat mongering for fear-mongering
um maybe that maybe there are
um you know as I said yesterday I
haven't spent a lot of time studying
these phenomena more being you know
kicked around by them
but that would be worth
looking at and I think in part you know
in the same way that the government is
opportunistic and is waiting for these
you know moments of disruption to push
additional authorities
um we probably should be doing the same
thing and know that we're going to have
these windows that are created by you
know big media events I think you
actually will see that pattern that our
big kind of high profile lawsuits are
filed six days after you know the
massive League story and so we're kind
of trying to to ride that wave in some
way and to to make sure that that
person's risk
is converted into some legal or social
change
but I I'm going to think more about that
so thank you so much for the talk
um
I wanted to ask a question about the
relationship between the National
Security State and like the military
budget and like the military-industrial
complex more broadly because I think you
made the point that rhetorically
American politics has kind of moved on
from the war on terror as a source of
fixation
um and one of the things that I thought
of is that despite that kind of
rhetorical moving on uh the kind of
material basis of that um
you know that
kind of a rhetorical fixation what the
military budget has continued to grow
and so I'm wondering the extent to which
you've experienced a kind of integration
between
um the kind of broader
military-industrial complex that's not a
cringy term and no it is I mean I I
really think people I think that the
Eisenhower speech should be in in more
curricula it's short and it's really
powerful
um of course he delivered that speech as
he was leaving office and if anybody
could have had the authority during
eight years in office to do something
about it it was the leader of the Allied
Forces during World War II but even he
it was like I'll I'll save this for my
Parting Shot
um uh but no you're I mean you're
absolutely right and and uh and the
interplay between that budget and
classification is another aspect of it
there's a great book by William Arkin
and Dana priest about the sort of secret
surveillance budgets and even agencies
that we don't even really know about and
these things get built they vary rarely
get unbuilt
and you know that's why I talked about
institutional incentives more than
public fears are what's driving all of
this
foreign
hello
um I was thinking a little bit about
Upstream collection and recently I heard
a talk from someone who used to work at
the NSA and he said that one argument in
favor of
Upstream collection is that you know
it's not great that we're collecting
information from U.S citizens but we
currently just don't have the technology
to filter out Communications that aren't
about you know what the NSA is actually
targeting and until some magical filter
drops down from heaven this is the
reality that we're left with now there's
another possibility which is don't
collect everything
right it's true that if you collect
everything it's very hard to have a
magical filter that will tell you what's
a U.S citizen and not a US citizen but
if you think it's a problem that they're
collecting millions of communications
from U.S citizens a reasonable
alternative would be don't have that
program
right I mean was that a third option on
his menu
his argument was that you know in the
interim we should just allow yeah
the breaches of our constitutional
rights yeah well I mean this is what um
you know Keith Alexander who was the
head of the NSA for during this known
Revelations and before
um and a really brilliant bureaucrat and
the non-pejorative sense of that word
um you know his Mantra was collect it
all
and the authorities and the uses will
follow we can't even know if it's going
to be useful until we collect it all you
know I said this is like going into a
bar and said give me all of the drinks
so I can decide which one I want to
order right we have to collect
everything because it might actually be
useful and the thing is that's true I
mean I think like we need to actually
say that it's not helpful as a
predictive tool because if you collect
every communication in the world you've
built the world's biggest Haystack but
it's extremely useful as a forensic tool
so that once something has occurred you
have a surveillance time machine you can
rewind into your database and the dots
are always going to connect in hindsight
and that's why after every kind of
terrorist attack they say if only we've
been allowed to search all this
information that we had we would have
stopped that attack so you need to take
down the wall that prevents us from
looking at that and I guarantee you this
is what would happen now because you
know there are some restrictions on
their ability to search everything
that's collected although they do
another clever move which is they say
we're not targeting
U.S citizens we're targeting
non-citizens okay regrettably we get
millions of communications from U.S
citizens now we should be allowed to
search those Communications because they
were lawfully collected because we
weren't targeting U.S citizens right
they call that the back door search
um and yeah I mean why wouldn't they
want to I mean if you are in a security
agency and it's your job to prevent
things from happening to solve bad
things if they have it of course they're
going to want all of those things and I
don't criticize this person for wanting
it if someone else's job to tell them
you can't have it
yeah we start we end where we began
thanks a million Ben
um
so this is more just a sort of
historical perspective on on your
argument I mean maybe for the book more
than for now but it I mean it seems to
me
how much 9 11 was really a turning point
is somewhat debatable in that you know
we've seen over many decades a drift of
authority of a national security from
the other branches to the executive and
the concentration of authority within
the executive and you know this really
starts in the Truman Administration
where Congress with the blessing of the
Court gives up a lot of authority over
National Security to the executive
branch
and you know also I think I mean I think
there's
that 9 11 maybe was much more of a
scaling up of things that had been going
on for some time even in the 1990s the
NSA was was already authorizing a lot of
um surveillance and using various legal
loopholes to get it going so
I just you know it's just sort of
General Trend to towards deference to
Executive Authority that's being in
trained a very long time and it's not
just the sort of Post 9 11. I think
that's absolutely right and yeah you
could start with you know Truman signing
the National Security Act on the sacred
cow his Air Force One right as as our we
could start with the lectures there I do
think though that it's a little bit more
than a difference in degree and scale so
first of all on the surveillance side
the capabilities are night and day
different in 2006 from 1995 even and
2010 from 2006 just the ability
to collect
The Whole World's Communications and
store them at an affordable cost and
then search them that didn't exist
before 9 11. that capacity was created
after 9 11 and the decision was made to
deploy it all in secret before the
public had any kind of say and then to
install that as an architecture and then
I think the other point is you know as I
said you know continually to redefine
National Security to take on a longer
menu of threats that should not be
considered related to the National
Defense even like you know Lone Wolf
terrorist terrorists in the United
States and so but I think I think your
point is fundamentally right
which is I mean I know this because when
I was trying to litigate these cases in
2006 2007 2008 the government was citing
cases from the 1980s involving you know
surveillance and the state Secrets
privilege as well so
um uh so yes I I I think
um
I think if I were going to have more
than
two 50-minute lectures there would be a
chart that went like that well it needs
to be a book and you're the guy to write
it we'll see
wonderful thank you so much for this
Castle lectures and thank you everyone
for attending this today's really
thought provoking and fascinating and we
look forward to seeing the books thank
you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]